que ce soit le contour des nuages des montagnes
ou des galaxies de certaines hallucinations aux
formes de légumes tous ont quelque chose en
commun une beauté singulière un je ne sais
quoi d'envoûtant ce sont toutes des fractales
il existe plusieurs définitions géométriques
compliqué mais retenez juste pour le moment
qu'une forme ou vous pouvez zoomer à l'infini
en retrouvant la même forme et une fractale et si
je vous disais que derrière ces fractales et leurs
calculs se cache un secret qui changera le monde
si quantique est un mot à la mode pour parler des
technologies du futur tracta liste pourrait
bientôt inspiré autant d'engouement je suis
chercheur à l'université en mathématiques
dans le domaine des fractales et dans mon
laboratoire on a fait des découvertes fascinantes
que j'aimerais justement vous faire découvrir la
nature et l fractale c'est quand même incroyable
que la nature arrive à produire de tels géométrie
s'isoler de la même manière à toutes les échelles
et dans lesquels on peut plonger à l'infini grâce
au zoom d'un microscope on s'aperçoit que les
flocons de neige les choux et même vos poumons
sont fatales certains mathématicien envisage même
sérieusement que l'univers lui-même soit une sorte
de fractal gigantesque pas si improbable quand
on fait l'analogie entre la structure des amas
de galaxies formées par des système solaire qui
tourne autour d'un trou noir puis on demande des
planètes qui tournent autour d'une étoile des
électrons et c'est cette valse vertigineuse
semble se répliquer à tous les niveaux mais
pourquoi pourquoi la nature sans bet tel à
gré des structures si complexe qu est ce qu un
brocoli gagne avoir une forme géométrique dernier
cri plutôt qu'une vulgaire bout le cab aussi le
premier de ces avantages va vous donner le vertige
connaissez-vous un objet dont les contours sont
infinies mais qui puisse pour autant tenir dans la
paume de votre main pas si facile à imaginer mais
pourtant les fractales ont cette particularité
france a remis ce cube et retire chacun des
petites jupes du milieu pour créer des trous
dans ton casse tête maintenant divise chaque
petit cube restant en mini cube est persuadé
de la même manière et ainsi de suite recommence
jusqu'à l'infini les tranches lui plein de trous
que tu obtiens alors les matelas peine mais bon de
menger et croyez le ou non à force de le percer un
rapide calcul montre que son volume est devenu
presque nulle mais pas sa surface qui elle tend
vers l'infini une fractale c'est ce à l'infini à
portée de main à quoi ça peut bien servir regardez
par exemple votre portable comment les agences
et des millions de composants pour qu'il rentre
dans un si petit appareil en et wifi bluetooth
accéléromètre et j'en passe pour ça on utilise
des structure fractale ça se voyait beaucoup
plus sûre des anciens appareils électroniques
vous reçoit sanguins sont aussi organisés en
fractales des grosses artères qui se divise en
plus petits vaisseaux en z en capillaire etc si
bien que si on déroule et ouvriers soit sanguin
boutabout leur longueur ferai deux fois le tour
de la terre tout ça dans votre tout petit corps
c'est juste incroyable mais vous n'êtes pas
au bout de vos surprises vous avez peut-être
déjà aperçue ce genre d'image psychédélique ce
sont les hallucinations visuelles que certains
consommateurs de l esb peux voir ton cerveau
peut créer des décisions de fractale en effet
sous lsd les réseaux de neurones du cerveau
sont reconnectées différemment et il se peut
par exemple que le circuit censé réguler la zone
qui s'occupe de la vision soit dérouté autre part
du coup personne n'est plus là pour signaler
au cortex visuel qu'il a fini son job il se
met à tourner non stop en roue libre perd pied
et réanalyse des trucs qu'il a déjà analysé ce
qui donne l'impression de plonger dans des images
psychédéliques à n'en plus finir comme une sorte
de roll back un effet devises chez nous où sont
les mathématiques dans tout ça et si je te dis que
la nature a codé des fractales qui nous entourent
façon matrix à la base du délire ce n'est pas un
matin mais un biologiste la question qui se pose
est peut-on créer simplement la nature dont la
complexité est infinie c'est vrai difficile
d'étudier un organisme vivant si on doit se
trimballer des structures presque infini comme
nos vaisseaux sanguins ce biologiste va créer
un codage qui prendra son nom le système linder
meilleur le concept est archi simple vous prenez
deux lettres par exemple a et b et vous leur
attribuez à chacune des règles par exemple tous
les as se transforme en ab et tous les bébés se
transforme en tout est prêt il ne reste plus qu'à
choisir un point de départ prenons par exemple
on applique les règles une fois donc à devient
ab puis encore à b devient à b1 est encore à ba2
vient à ba1 à b1 et s'est très vite ça donne un
beau fruit de l'être mais un fouillis complètement
contrôlé par nos règles de départ c'est sympa ton
truc matin mais ça sert à quoi en fait la beauté
du truc c'est que sans vraiment s'en apercevoir
on vient de créer un arbre ne croyez pas regardez
il suffit d'afficher les a comme des branches les
baies comme des feuilles et de modifier légèrement
le système avec d'autres symboles et ta dah et si
vous changez un poil le système de départ vous
pouvez générer ou fougères si vous préférez d'où
vient cette magie si vous comptez le nombre de
lettres à chaque étape vous apercevez qu'il y en
a exactement la somme des deux étapes précédentes
à partir de simplement deux lettres et de règles
on est arrivé à coder ce qu'on appelle la suite
de fibonacci rien de magique juste en suivant nos
règles très simples la nature a donné naissance
à une fractale la suite de fibonacci d'un objet
mathématique fondamental dans la nature puisqu'il
donne forme aux spirales de coquillages des
galaxies regardez cette pomme de pain elle est
jolie n'est ce pas essayer de compter le nombre
de spirale bon si vous me dites 12 ou encore
14 bah c'est impossible il y en a forcément un
nombre de la suite de fibonacci dans ce cas la
réponse était 13 est ce que je vous raconte ne
s'arrête pas à la pomme de pain mais se retrouve
chez les marguerites les choux et j'en passe
fibonacci revient dans de nombreux concepts
lorsqu'on parle du nombre d'or ou de la théorie
du chaos un exemple avez vous déjà vu le double
pendule du dr nordmann son mouvement est tellement
chaotique on n'arrive pas à le prédire eh bien
on peut modéliser sa trajectoire grâce à des
fractales même des choses aussi improbable que la
reproduction des lapins cage des fractales voici
l'équation mathématique de leur évolution et selon
le taux de croissance que vous allez prendre pour
votre suite en gros si vous là inquiète beaucoup
pas votre population va évoluer normalement sauf
si votre taux dépasse 3 là les choses deviennent
beaucoup plus intéressante magnifique fractales
n'est ce pas elle n'est pas seulement belle mais
surtout très utile grâce à ces résultats observés
dans la nature des chercheurs ont par exemple
réussi à mettre en place des appareils pour
soigner des coeurs malades la chaîne d'irritation
m'en parle dans cette superbe vidéo tout ça pour
vous montrer à quel point les fractales sont
omniprésents dans notre quotidien comment
mesurer l'infini quelle est la longueur des côtes
du royaume uni une question d'apparence 1 mais qui
semble turlupiner pas mal de spécialistes on peut
essayer de les mesurer sur une carte mais voici le
problème simon zoom on découvre d'autres replis
qui augmente la longueur et plus on s'approche
plus cette longueur augmente on peut toujours
rajouter le tour d'un rocher d'un caillou d'un
grain de sable et ça n'en finit plus de s'agrandir
vous l'avez compris le bord de mer est donc aussi
une forme fractales les côtes du royaume uni
ont une longueur infinie enfin pas tout à fait
en pratique difficile de zoom est plus petit que
l'atome donc nous irons presque infinies bon on va
pas se mentir cette réponse ne va pas convaincre
grand monde et en plus elle n'est pas utile du
tout puisqu'il n'y a aucun moyen de comparer la
taille des côtes du royaume uni avec celles de
la norvège le problème est que la ligne de la côte
est tellement tarabiscoté qu'on dirait qu'elle est
épaisse comme si elle n'était plus totalement une
ligne fine mais un objet qui commence à avoir une
largeur pas encore une surface mais assurément
plus une ligne infiniment fine quelque chose
entre les deux regardez c'est plus parlant avec
cette fractale au départ on a bien une ligne qui
n'a pas de largeur juste une longueur elle est en
une dimension mais quand on commence à l'affairé
xavier avec des va et vient de plus en plus
resserré elle remplit progressivement le carré
dans lequel on l'a placé jusqu'à l'occupé
complètement on se retrouve à la fin avec
une surface plein en deux dimensions longueur et
largeur pourtant vous êtes d'accord que ce carré
on ne la remplit qu'avec une ligne un objet inde
et en large en sang selon une forme fractale on a
donné une surface à un objet qui n'en avait pas
on l'a fait sauter dans la dimension supérieure
cette courbe n'est donc plus tout à fait une ligne
tout à fait un plan mais quelque chose entre les
deux on ne peut donc ni mesurer sa longueur qui
est infinie ni sa surface qui est nul déroutant
nom et le fait que les fractales puisse avoir des
longueurs ou des surfaces infinie ça soulève pas
mal de problématique imaginez les mathématiciens à
la cantine qui se mettent à se poser des questions
existentielles du genre puisque le chou romanesco
est une fractale sa surface est infinie ça veut
dire que pour recouvrir mon assiette j'aurai
besoin d'une quantité infinie de sauce béchamel
un mathématicien outdoor va résoudre ce problème
en introduisant des dimensions intermédiaire entre
les dimensions entière que nous connaissons n
la longueur dimension un la surface dimension 2
et le volume dimension 3 il va expliquer qu'il
existe plein d'autres dimensions non un tiers
dimension 1,2 à 1,7 2,99 si vous avez du mal
à comprendre à quoi ça correspond c'est normal
disons que ça indique à quel point un objet à des
replis resserré c'est entre dimensions permettent
ainsi de classer les fractales selon si elles
sont plus ou moins tarabiscoté pourrait être
une fractale pas besoin d'être auto similaires
il suffit de vivre dans ses dimensions non un
tiers par exemple les côtes de grande bretagne
ont une dimension fractales d'environ 1,25 quant
aux chaudes romanesco sa dimension fractales est
d'environ 2,66 pour vos poumons dont les alvéoles
possède des multiples recoins pour capter un
maximum des recettes environ 2,9 ces chiffres
ne sortent pas de nulle part vous voulez avoir une
idée de comment les calculs on peut appliquer la
formule de la dimension de outdoor bon je vous
rassure les mathématiciens eux mêmes galères sur
ce calcul car c'est très abstrait mais du coup ils
préfèrent estimé la dimension de boîte vous prenez
un feutre gris et vous couriez toutes les cases
que touchent votre fractale ici les côtes de la
grande bretagne puis vous prenez une des plus
fines et vous recommencez à la fin pour chaque
grille vous placer sur ce graphique le point
qui correspond au nombre de carreaux coloriée
en fonction de la taille des carreaux en riant ces
points vous remarqué que aubin magie ils sont tous
alignés vous trouverez une belle droite que les
scientifiques adorent car sa pente indique la
dimension fractales de notre objet tada grâce à ce
chiffre on peut enfin mesurer les fractales sans
tomber sur des résultats absurdes ou rencontrer
l'un finit donc plus besoin d'une infinité de
béchamel pour recouvrir votre chou pas de
pénurie en vue un futur fait de fractal six
dimensions intermédiaires sont présentes partout
dans la nature comme on l'a vu ce qui en fait un
outil très puissant puisque on peut l'appliquer à
quasi n'importe quoi biologie chimie physique et
ingénierie voici comment j'utilise ces calculs au
quotidien dans mes recherches regardez par exemple
ces signaux en hausse ce sont les battements
cardiaques d'un coureur de marathon surentraînés
en bas ceux d'une personne lambda à première
vue pas vraiment moyen de les différencier
si on vous demandait de discerner qui est qui
vous seriez bien embêté même pour la x perdre
un médecin il n'y a aucun moyen de les distinguer
tellement les différences sont imperceptibles est
fluctuante aucune technique d'analysé classiques
ne peut mettre en évidence des caractéristiques
flagrante mais grâce aux fractales tout devient
clair pour chaque portion de la courbe on peut
calculer sa dimension fractales plus la courbe
est irrégulière en cet endroit plus sa dimension
fractales sera élevé on parle aussi de rugosité
on l'exposera par un nombre compris entre 0 et 1
si on regarde à gauche on a par exemple représenté
en rouge des proportions très rugueuse et anvers
à droite des proportions plus régulière ces deux
ensembles de poing forme des fractales différentes
pour que ça soit lisible on n'a qu'à regrouper
les points de même couleur qui partagent la même
rugosité cuite calculer sa dimension fractales
comme on l'a vu précédemment quand on effectue
ce classement on obtient une belle courbe qui nous
montre de quelle façon la courbe et fractale on
appelle ça le spectre multi fractales une sorte de
carte d'identité maintenant la différence entre le
marathonien et le nom sportif est carrément plus
flagrante sur ce spectre on va pouvoir déceler des
caractéristiques auparavant invisibles l'intérêt
de toutes les recherches est de savoir ce qu'il
se passe dans le coeur d'un coureur lorsque
celui-ci s'entraîne ou encore mieux savoir
détecter des pathologies cardiaques avec une
grande précision grâce à un simple enregistrement
lorsqu on s'est rendu compte de ça on a direct eu
l'idée d'utiliser dans l'art et ceux qui n'étaient
pas visibles à l'oeil nu sur des tableaux de biens
obvious sur leurs spectres fractales par rapport
aux toiles de maîtres toutes les répliques même
les copies les plus fidèles ont un spectre décaler
vers la droite qu'il crut les mathématiques ont
trouvé un moyen de démasquer les faux en art et
ce n'est que le début à chaque nouveau signal
analysé découvre de nouvelles caractéristiques
caché en finance en urbanisme en médecine et bien
d'autres encore l'analyse multi fractales est un
outil dont on commence à peine à percevoir les
possibilités j'espère vous avoir transmis un peu
de mon enthousiasme et avoir cassé quelques idées
reçues sur la recherche mathématique car ce n'est
pas juste d'être assis devant des équations
incompréhensible et attendre d'avoir une idée
c'est de la création des moments d'excitation des
tâtonnements des déceptions des collaborations
bref toute une aventure dans mes journées je
lis des livres très spécialisés ou des articles
pointus son sujet je calcule tests mes théories et
mes idées pour espérer atteindre un gros résultat
de fait des simulations pour illustrer et je
regarde c'est ce que j'ai trouvé s'applique à
d'autres domaines et enfin je discute il échange
avec d'autres chercheurs pour en apprendre plus
et aller encore plus loin que ce soit lors d'une
réunion ou lors de conférences l'objectif final
est de pouvoir rédiger un article propre rigoureux
et riche en contenu pour pouvoir le soumettre dans
une revue qui permettra aux chercheurs qui la
liront d'utiliser ses résultats pour avancer
dans leurs propres recherches et repousser
encore les limites de nos connaissances car
on l'oublié avec tous les prix qu'on donne mais
la recherche n'est pas le fruit d'une personne
mais d'une lignée de chercheurs du plus modestes
aux plus illustres j'espère que cette vidéo très
personnel vous a plu si vous voulez en savoir plus
n'hésitez pas à aller voir mon site internet ou à
lire des articles je parle entre autres de mes
recherches sur les séries aléatoire d'anglet
où vous pouvez aussi me suivre directement
sur twitter ou instagram c'était guillaume
cesse alias Matart et d'Antoine et de pleins
d'amis mathématiciens je vous dis à bientôt ciao
oui